You're overthinking everything.
He says, I guess it's the GMB that throws me for a loop.
Why does that?
And you don't have to answer this.
This is a rhetorical question for everybody.
I have not lost a second of sleep over a GMB, guys.
There's three ways to get leads on Google.
There's paid ads, there's the Google My Business,
AKA the Maps, and there's organic.
Guess what?
99% of the people out there
don't know how to run Google Ads.
All the people doing rank and rent
So guess what?
Their only chance is organic and maps.
And guess what?
Maps just got taken.
So they have one.
And when I say taken, there's still ways to get ranked,
or there's still ways to get verified, obviously,
but it's not as easy as it was
where you just throw it up and it goes.
They only have one way to get leads, right?
Guess what?
It may not be as easy for us to get the GMB,
but we still have ads.
We still have organic.
So that's why I'm saying focus on
how competitive is the organic?
Because if you can get ranked organically
and you can get the ads to supplement,
you will be fine.
In 2020, I don't know how many projects I had
by the time I was making 100K,
but I will tell you that more than half of those
did not have a verified GMB.
We were making money.
We had contracts that business owners were happy
strictly on ads and organic.
And a lot of the organic was taking a while to catch up.
So guys, stop stressing about that.
Don't give up on it.
Not saying to stop trying to figure out ways
that are ethical, that are white hat,
that are above board,
but don't sweat it.
I've never even lost a second of sleep on this whole,
everyone's in their freaking pants about this.
Like, what are we going to do?
What are we going to do?
Just quit stressing, okay?
And I know that's hard
because I'm a stressor when certain areas,
but I'm just telling you for this,
don't stress, okay?